so I thought that I would you know ask
some questions with your mom to bring
things out of that communal land is
worthless I can't do that i'm going to
do now and a bit about Denise place in
plans right now and with the French they
could talk about the United States and
why I'm particularly happy that his book
on huge in America is now in multan
English anyone who lives in France for
any in America pollutes from France or
any period of time to learn how ignorant
in general the French are about the
United States now that's true every
country we go to is no reason why they
should know as much about you countries
even if that country plays a big role in
the idea of the country but more
straighten to me is the lack of
curiosity about the United States of
France I mean real curiosity curiosity a
door open the hood of a car I just want
to figure out how does it work this
thing actually work and that's rare I
mean I think it's struggling to me just
to compare them people young French
people to young Germans or Italians or
French in general the Germans Italians
in French visit the United States an
early age it's part of their who you
know the part of their ticket to have to
punch to come the state's get on a
Greyhound bus across the country
especially the Germans are all it will
go to any black church anywhere to have
a real American experience and Texas it
do all that because to be germany yet
understand America that's part of what
it is to understand yourself oxen and
their English to excellent English the
Germans and
better English and video the french man
speaking french will young french people
they don't spend a lot of time with
american television is getting better
because the internet but in general is
just a striking lack of curiosity about
united straight stays and I think it's
given rise to both a screen of
anti-americanism of which
about which DNI's as written but also
strange rules pearl Americans that are
the product of the fantasy as well you
remember the line from oscar wilde's it
wants to be earnest pray don't talk to
me about the weather mr. Worthington
whenever people talk to me about the
weather I always feel quite certain they
mean something else and that makes me so
nervous I feel the same of the French
talk about the United States if you know
when they're talking about the u.s.
they're really talking about something
else and not about real existing America
I think this week include out better or
it's been good for me I lived in Paris
Paris universe appears of my life but I
was in nineteen eighty eight and
nineteen ninety so I was there for all
the permits wall and I was also there
for the DS home to nap
and it was an extraordinary moment for
thinking about America it was also IPO
phase moment in French intellectual
culture it did indeed seem that two
hundred year history had come to an end
that a certain democratic drama that has
pitted two revolutions against each
other in the 18th century had come to an
end with one model being dominant and
the other having failed so the end of an
illusion in his terms and the rise of
his problematic about democracy and
around few Fame and around magazines
that you say Bob and disply you saw
develop a kind of doctrine of about
politics in which the US played a
crucial role with my several shin and
pmno there you can get an apocalyptic
picture of the rise of modern democracy
and individualism
on the other extreme yet people a hue
people get ski and play on we had a more
like it at light-hearted tape on
American popular culture changes in
fashion the weird little things we do
their anti-smoking legislation it's just
odd things that democracies do and
especially in the United States and I'd
say that that was very instructive for
me to see the u.s. from outside in that
way and through a particular land but
the further away I I can see that it was
everything revolved on a single theme
which is an amalgam of dopey movie dhoom
oh and could yet
that there was this world historical
drama that had taken place at landed
Francis turn position and but reading
America you were able to reach into the
future that's essentially how things
work provide a staircase
and it was good to get away from a kind
of more provincial in the US and getting
excited about the things people excited
up at Mallik little crackers what the
total drum is still being beaten in and
friendly and i'm more more surprised
about my friends were writing move in
writing these things i would curious
that remain about the states from the
most obvious thing to understand
american that i watch American TV that
America Reads itself through American
television there is no tedious to begin
with and they are unwilling to get their
fingers dirty to pay attention to swim
in the strange pond that is America and
the more of either works would think
about them thought about
appreciate it looks up in unicorn
is for me one of the rarest of birds in
France someone genuinely curious an
open-minded of us speaks color
colloquial American English and spend a
lot of time here just observing when
Denis talks about the weather sorry
about the weather now when he talks
about the u.s. is actually still is a
difference when you reduce both you do
get a tank on us that is unusual there's
a woman's particularly American
Historians I've talked to each other
about the same things the innocence of
distance and perspective in what he
writes Denis has learned from Tokyo took
who plays a role in the latest book but
he doesn't stop there his book seemed to
do two things simultaneously on one hand
he lectures the French about the way
things really are here and on the other
hand he tells us what we looked like
from the outside as I said on the blue
to latest book and I meant it didn't eat
seemed sometimes to understand us better
than we understand ourselves
yeah an example of this is the book that
I feel I know the best and that's likely
to be don't you take medi-cal let me say
a couple words about that before turning
off or what makes that look special to
give you a sense of what's special about
these books and their author now please
was published in 1997 and it was i'm
guessing consume not only is a book
about the US but as an intervention in
current french debates about
multiculturalism in which the u.s.
example was being used and misused it
was a time when many people were
praising the united states and what can
fans
us can do it why can't we be as money
cultural as they are others on the other
hand we're using the image of the United
States to scare others to say that our
multiculturalism was eroding our sense
of citizenship and if that's what we
want to commend the end in French
republicanism in all of this almost as
much people were paying attention to the
strange paradoxes and the nature of
American multiculturalism in the
tensions within the United States in an
American history about enemies question
in response Geneva suggested that
multiculturalism is a unique than the
American experience with it is unique to
the United States the way it can sees
itself as a regime and it goes to the
harbor match national self-identity
national identity and also the
contradictions in our identity
according to two strains in American
political culture that begin rising you
before the American ally on the one hand
the tradition of Tolerance especially
tolerance of religion in the early
colonies that though very quickly led to
a reaction and mainly over the question
of assimilation if America was a new
kind of regime than its own level
everyone had to be with the program and
that meant perhaps i ee intellectually
but also culturally and these two sides
of the debate in two different
understanding of what America is about
that keep kept returning attention at
the end of the nineteenth and early
twentieth century louise new immigration
and and now today the tension between
being a civic nation and an ethnic
nation is that the harder it is to be
America the point was to say there is no
American model that the French can argue
about a single American model that they
can hold up is something that's
attractive or frightening rather the
United States is a contest between two
principles having to do with split not
on our minds and it looks in both of
these in this book with sympathy
stands what do to them try to achieve
but also their limitations and so doing
mine in the French just how complicated
these questions are on one hand on the
other that the French problems another
problem and it was time for us to stop
talking about the American example and
to pay more attention to the real
challenges posed by immigration and
tolerance he travels today for me it was
just an eye-opening book about the US
and also about French debates indirectly
well in his recent book religion in
America is done again enough mistake
much about he's going to talk about it
but again I see it as a very interesting
intervention there's another crisis
these republicanism now having to do
with Islam in France and again us in
held up as a model and that's a panty
model and again it's based on ignorance
there's an assumption in France that the
Protestant heritage is at war with
enlightenment a religious principle the
last 10 years of war secular one
men and the two can never win / x and
did you chose a brilliant way that this
just is not a case that both of these
strains are present in our thinking and
our natures Americans indiana's written
and lightning book and against again
he's managed to survive by the book read
a book and Alison up here because this
moving on
my name's alex deleon I'm thrilled that
Tennessee era because he said something
great about friendship and it's about
one thing is that in this institution oh
penne with the first ball Charles Taylor
distinguished scholar in residence inn
that we had and he created the mop-up
what you should eat when you're in a
statement professor the residents open
to the students open to the faculty
doing major work a delight to hacker and
helped out on all sorts of things and
this he intended I think I allow it a
lot of my course so he ended up
co-teaching then admitting the students
with it so it was the best possible type
of a lion scholarship fellowship and the
question about and this we now have 14
books in our series this is one of the
absolute responses the first one
accepted and gave the whole series some
credibility with Columbia University
Press and I thank you for that and it's
interesting on the question of
friendship and respect I ask
preface to this second would I then when
I heard him sorry I wrote my notes a
book I I know you can't and don't
under any responsibility to write down
four days after Tony died the preface of
life it obviously was one of the things
that he did in the last two days of his
life because that's the respect that he
has for Speed rent in the problem thank
you so much of his difficult start after
so in a flattering cummins but I'm very
grateful for our invited me here and
convinced me that the book should come
out in English and for mark some
comments or which are based not just on
this book of previous books as well and
that
was wonderful on his part and also I'm
glad we both can judge it was an
unexpected gift I thought that you
preface and my great surprise and so I'm
grateful to all of you it's an
appointment to introduce a topic so let
me directly talk about other tensions of
the wine you vote by Martina tensions
between that's going to first part of my
talk of our early narratives of the
american national identity and competing
their days of the American identity and
then secondly look at the revival of
those narratives of the American
identity in the twentieth and
twenty-first century so whatever I came
back to the United States it's always
and that's pretty often that's two or
three times a year it's always
surprising for me to see how prevalent
is religion in america in politics are
less summer I was in California as much
talk about Governor Perry's Day of
Prayer Texas called the response in
which at the time he hadn't decided that
we would run the primaries and a day of
prayer in which the future candidate
declared the quarries love for the
living Christ of their prayer which by
definition could not make a lung
Christian or even a Catholic tear
comfortable but that's Texas for you and
as a French political scientist is
written on the origin under the American
Republic actually at the time of the
bicentennial of those evoke by Mark Lyra
and look at the affinities between
french and american political thought in
18th century i even wrote once an
article called the trade of republican
ideas between france and the united
states it's always difficult coming from
France to explain this exuberant
religiosity in the United States and to
reconcile it with with ways from an
undeniable reality namely the secular
foundation of the American government a
sacred foundation which by the way was
greatly admired by a French and to a
certain extent by number of British
observers at the same time so the
challenge then is to explain the
coexistence of what I call us to two
radically different trends in religious
tradition that invites American
politicians to talk openly about their
own faith incites them to defend and
promote religious ideas or symbols in
the public square and on the other
another tradition that insists on the
necessity to preserve separation of
church and state and there's an obvious
clash between let's say openly religious
Republicans and more secular less
obviously religious Democrats of course
that wasn't always the case
that has a lot to do with Southern
Strategy of the Republican Party which
is really something that bird shot in
60s particularly rich our climax on
Derby Carter's administration so the
book is an attempt to explain competing
values and to place those values in a
long historical perspective and also in
a comparative perspective what matters
firm is not religion as an isolated
phenomena but the uses of religion by
political elites and by its lecturers in
order to create a reinvent a national
identity and national identities are
always difficult to define because they
are the center of historical
controversies rival discourses
narratives inventions reconstruction and
so on and as an added difficulty in
United States because the chronology of
events is very different from that of
year perhaps with the exception of
Germany that is to say and I think the
historian John hearing put it
beautifully off he says the following in
the United States the constitutional
roof was built before national walls
revolution created a political system a
political regime but it took over
century and similar to solidify the
national walls and so the starting point
of the argument is from a European
perspective there's not one narrative
but at least two rival narratives of
America
identity first run call it a creation
story our secondary Republic which had a
lot in common with the French Republic
or a friend Republican tradition and
which promotes key principles with which
you're quite familiar in the idea of
equality of sovereignty of the people
the audience entering churches they so
on and so forth and the idea that our
republic is by definition opposed to a
monarchy that is to say there is no
divine right power there is no
established church and that's those are
very important thing which are visible
admittedly read the Declaration of
Independence that's what it's all about
a republic which can be sent here hence
the unpopular notion defended by some
American story and I think about my
friend Isaac ram nagar road is this
important book called the godless
Constitution and then the second
narrative which I called New Cureton or
romantic and I'll explain why is really
something which became fashionable
little later at the beginning of the
19th century and which in fact denies
the secular nature of the American
government gives tremendous importance
not semestre founding fathers who are
forgotten as the pilgrims and to the
Puritans it's another creation story
which was reinvented leg were early New
England but reinvented at the national
level in the 19th century by a number of
historians and the most prominent of
them being George Bancroft with his
famous 10 volume his
all the United States the first volume
was published in nineteen thirty for one
year before prevailed democracy in
America 18 18 34 and graph 1835 first
one in petroleum so let me start remove
the secular narrative first one which
emphasizes sent saturation church and
state and toleration it's of course not
something not an American invention but
you can read unlock about it find early
elemental separation you can leave Roger
Williams also but what's interesting for
me coming from friends is the way
enlightenment philosophers discuss the
pyramids in general and in North America
and usually of London philosophers saw
the Puritans as zealous as dangerous
vanities including John Locke John Locke
for instance in the letter toleration
attacks the calvinist for having used I
psyche John what bloody violence to for
the execution we shall say obey who s
auburn to name Geneva 1553 from there is
another very good example of a
philosopher who finds religion in
general dendrons because they should or
later lead to finances and in his friend
examine me nobody bought 20 announces
the stupidity of fanaticism and of all
Christian millen areas that are called
cristie kerr and
who out there literally except the book
of Revelation and made for the dimension
prediction that a New Jerusalem would
descend from the earth the result of
such analysis and was that Europe was
drowned in an ocean of blood not going
from from tail so yeah numerous evidence
that the Puritans are not liking you
it's the article Puritan DeRozan
superiority very critical there's a
behind not a famous history of the two
indices which was republished many times
in Europe and in France around 1780 and
brain through until book about the
colonization of the Americas and of
North America repeated many times and I
know about when he talks about the
Puritans German settlers whether the
side grab on when they accomplished
great things and myths but very quickly
says that well the success was partly
due to the help of local Indians the
welcoming presence puts it of a few
savages and yet and it's great to start
by that couple of years later hatchets
you know a century later our captain
John lover well will murder and local
Indians near Boston the White Mountains
of New Hampshire effect and so I now
concludes his section on the Puritans
for the following a question where you
Christians know you were monsters of
extermination angle and he sees the
Puritans as a variant of the type of
modern variable that can kiss the doors
that's the way in Europe would talk
about periods and these harsh criticism
of American
religious successes of course doesn't
imply that religion was rejected in
general and again if you come back to
work there as a major exception from
Voltaire another French philosophers and
that's the fragrance record printer is a
perceptive Frenchman is I an ideal
utopian religion it's a religion for a
non-religious egg and what fascinates
won't air is that in paper that you have
a religion a government without priests
with that sacrament with that communion
and aunt I'm catalysis evacuation and
praises that type of religion and
started a collision all the French
visitors who go to North America well
come of tear in your pocketbook try to
meet crackers in Philadelphia and some
will be enthusiastic but what they see
others will be disappointed depending on
the time and we visit but basically let
me come back then to this first send a
narrative American identity I think it's
really at the heart of a very important
dialogue we forgotten how I probably was
that took place between the successor of
deed rose and cyclopedia Dylan you
publish our security method ich in
between 1784 and 1786 its index raises
an American Frank remember that involve
devenir one side is no se crea 14
articles on the United States one person
a plus one
lizard as a knee and medicine Jefferson
are the are the other side and with a
great fascination for Jefferson's bill
for establishing religious freedom which
was probably no drafted early in 1777
but did not become law in Virginia until
1786 thanks to the very active lobbying
of medicine and it's a law that purpose
of the lowest to disestablish the enemy
church to abolish all religious oaths of
religions to make sure that no tax is
collected for church or for a school on
religious school that bill was
immediately translated the earth
Americans transmitted to French
published that senior in delineating
secure PDF full translation and was
discussed three years before the French
Revolution there was a discussion about
the importance of separation of church
and state in Virginia and Virginia was
presented as comedy universal model for
a revolution to come and a secularism to
come and dividend by the way great to
secure person he was the century of
Monsieur refused the name of Louisa
sixteenth brother and I was a lawyer by
training and
well a few survived the French
Revolution was at any direct linking our
state's recovery before it went back to
France a name I think work to result in
a consulate or was a elected official
under Napoleon so besides this
franco-american dialogue you find the
same interesting dialogue between of
radical twigs and breaking and American
families and i'll give you one examine
you all know about tom paine but less
well known is the case of jamesburg
james birth is a radical wig the author
of a book called critters to volume of
essays and volume to a crit oh that's
published in 1767 his dedicated quote to
the good people of Britain of the year
of the 20th century so it's a utopia for
a future age and by the way it's a
classic thing to do when you write it
utopia out one way for you to criticize
a government without being penalized for
criticizing the monarch because you
place that in the distant future and in
fact it's a deconstruction systematic
deconstruction of British monarchy and
bird are invents the phrase wall of
separation in that time book second book
any tax breaks in the lips mongrel
spiritual temporal secular and
ecclesiastical establishment of the
monarchy and ask for privatization of
church functions calls for the abolition
of the test act which
not be abolished in Britain nutshell if
i'm not mistaken in 1839 and asked the
good people of Britain of the 20th
century could build an impenetrable wall
separation between things sacred and
soon now we know and our drives bags
pregunta legal historian as demonstrated
that in fact our trio had been bred by
Jefferson Jefferson owned the work of
Ginsberg and probably found his
inspiration for the famous Jefferson
letter to the Baptist community of
Danbury probably found inspiration in
gentlemen so now let me consider the
second nuclear narrative of American
identity which I call new Puritan or
romantic let me explain what I mean by
that now in the 19th century core the
consensus among intellectuals at the
French Revolution fail terror and as
ended in the disaster and it's a time
and that's why I call it romantic when
tradition religious values religious
emotions are being rediscovered and
praised and also there's a passion for
medieval studies potent quote ancestors
great ancestors a unit primitivo the
past and great the goals assassins the
Germanic tribes of Germany of course are
all praised and honored and there's a
new historical or mr. a graphic fashion
that develops and it's really the idea
that in order to understand a natural
identity
look to consider to identify the
character of the people or the spirit of
the people that's what bankruptcies so
also Antonio series for instance when it
says typical example of this nurse story
ography he says quote democracy in
America the character of a nation is
contained in it sergeant music road in a
manner of speaking cest reveal the whole
man already lies sweat old in his cradle
and that's embarrassing chapter true
democracy in America which is entitled
on the point of departure and its
importance for the future of Anglo
Americans so character the spirit of the
nation that's where it starts and the
German one set of all Geist's it's the
same as the same meaning and to be found
in offending people and as the heart of
a romantic imagination think of herder
think of the Schlegel brothers think of
our fishy friends think of Gazoo in the
United States think of John Quincy Adams
Daniel Webster and of course Georges
Bank Roth and never forget that Georges
Bank roth who was a kind of boy genius
he graduated from Harvard at age 14 that
was sent to Germany from 1818 to 1822 he
studied at gun guns that in a berlin by
Mark II took courses from plunk on
church history purses from Voeckler
tacitus the one who rediscovered the
importance of Germania
Germanic tribes possibly have tasteful
liberty freedom he studied theology
which linebacker history would hear was
a disciple of her dance and so forth so
in the United States if you look at the
origin and raise a question who
represents best the spirit of the
American people but phone guys from the
American people so difficult question
indeed because Tocqueville and bancroft
admit that the colonization started in
Virginia not in North not in doing it
but Virginia's not a good case
motivation was not religious those
people who came to Virginia where gold
diggers and not honorable for a trophy
libera unscrupulous and undisciplined
men and if you break it at American
Indians weren't you left with the New
England the Pilgrims and Puritans and
we'd argue that Bancroft did for America
but essences have done from the Germans
it would rehabilitation grains mocked
and denigrated by enlightenment
philosophers and i should add superbly
ignored by the Fanning fathers there's
not a single reference to the Puritans
in Federalist Papers for lemons RK h is
no point in talking back so then crop
marks the triumph of New England of my
story ography and bankers argument of
really really is that the character of
pilgrim shaped the new American
nationality and climax of course of the
narrative that's
may fire cabin where I site bancroft
humanity recovers its rights and birth
of constitutional liberty takes place
now it's a new narrative which you find
developed almost exactly the same term
in intervals democracy in America
publisher a banker the only one knew the
other bread the others manuscript I mean
this was the age and and it's also
providential conception of American
history society that they are kind of
marvelous continuity from Luther and
Calvin to the Puritans of New England
where they an improved notion of Liberty
that develops and man and pops out as a
modern repeal and quote from Bancroft
the Puritan splintered of the soil of
her virgin country quote the seminal
principles of Republican freedom and
independence and growth and Tom Vale
would say very much the same looking at
they Mayflower Compact that site but
without the references to the king
loyalty to the king which would give it
a less Republican appearance so Tobias
qualities kind of tactical and it
compares that to it's almost like the
genuine social contract says prevailing
a note that was discovered recently
social contract in the lines drank five
was so now of course there are number
modern historians specialists of New
England history today that have
questioned the centrality of the
Mayflower Compact which in fact was very
much an active circumstance designed to
prevent a near mutiny aboard the
Mayflower or we can go to detail there
so basically what we have is advocates
of this mill cureton narrative that will
create work very hard to create a new
cult of ancestors symbolizing the genius
of the American people and bancroft will
send the end of all in one of the
history the United States he will talk
about sublimity of the pilgrims at
Plymouth and at the stage of which set
of pilgrims really displace the family
farms now let me examine I'm going to
skip the part that's about year 19th
century early 20th century my birkenhead
let's exactly ryan hall and a second
half of i talk to revival of both the
second secular narrative on one hand and
the ilk your narrative in the late 20th
century 21st century now in the 20th
century the secular narrative which was
defended by by jefferson and others was
really rediscovered by progressive
justices of the Supreme Court and I
would argue that this paradigm still
works more or less today in the Supreme
Court despite numerous attempt to break
down the wall separation between church
and state and a classic decision the
Everson decision of 1947 the best
illustration of this revival for tourism
because number one it applies the
Establishment Clause of the First
Amendment to all the states through the
doctrine ation so through the
doctrine of incorporation and certainly
it is based on a very interesting
historical research methodology re
reading of Jefferson's letter to the
Baptist of them URI and it's a decision
where the Justice black concludes his
opinion for the following words the
First Amendment has erected a wall chirp
between church and state but wall was
behind impregnable who would not accept
the slightest freak and quote now the
reality and may be different in fact if
you look carefully at that opinion which
is about financing public financing or
transportation of students due to
Catholic schools in fact the opinion was
that this was not a contradiction that
that was not invalidated by the
Establishment Clause but that's beside
the point but what's interesting is the
rediscovery of the metaphor by Justice
black and why is that so and again as a
historian if you look at the way he
proceeds what's fascinating is that uses
case law and there are not too many
early cases filled with religious of
free exercise or or establishment clause
that one case that's important for
justice black is the Reynolds decision
of 1879 a decision about a federal law
that criminalizes Glee to me at the time
in the mornings were still territory and
trying to
preserve that tradition polygamy and the
court's decision was that but no llegan
is not not acceptable and what's
interesting is that that other case
Reynolds was written by Justice wait and
why was wait there are wonderful amex in
this case where you find full text of
the bill and religious freedom by
Jefferson medicines are writings the
famous letter to the Danbury Baptists
community so the key question from start
over why this passion for early for late
18th century text that having forgotten
and the response which is suggested by
rice bag is the phone make it happen
that wait lived in the neighborhood that
was such a rush in DC his neighbor in
fact was George Bancroft and George Van
Praagh fed him with all historical
documents that have been printed or that
printed but rediscovered and so given
that information and in fact we know
that because Wade st. is famous neighbor
for the transmission of broad historical
facts that helping decide the case so
today I would argue that the true
guardians of the wall separation between
churches they are federal judges and
justices Supreme Court especially
progressive justices but of course the
jurisprudence has evolved and you have
what I would call separatists on 1a
lawyers preferable and separation lists
and anti separated I'm going to go to
detail here but basically what's the
viewpoint of the separatists is that we
have a number of plastic decisions the
ban on school prayers on public school
the ban on the display of Christmas
nativity scene in public square the ban
on the display of Ten Commandments in
the courthouse or in classrooms all
those some of which are quite recent
decision demonstrate a commitment
through the separation of Triple C and
the key reasoning often involved there
is a principal government neutrality and
the idea that which is often cited I
think justice Souter for instance in a
recent case but it's it's an opinion
that sites and it's often cited its
vigilant and
by Justice O'Connor which is that it
religious display whatever its nature
when it's across prayer tape tablets for
the Tenth Amendment those religious this
way cannot be tolerated in public space
if court they send a message to
knowledge adherence that they are
outsiders not full members of the
political community and an accompanying
message to the hearings that they are
insiders favorite members which means
what it means that there's no preferred
religion in the United States or for
that matter no predominant religion in
the United States Citizenship is
perceived as all inclusive and every
religious faith as its place including
pagan religion including Santeria fetish
decision by springboard call the church
of the Luca me Baloo I which tolerates
animal sacrifices in Florida even though
that violates local ordinance that
prohibits cruelty to animals so
basically every religion is respectable
and non-religion is also respectable and
then let's examine the revival of the
milk Eureka narrative weeks a revival in
the courts in political science and in
mainstream politics in the course that
revived all you find it with
conservative justices for instance late
justice rehnquist and today probably
about Justice Thomas and Scalia and
their position really is that of an anti
separates they don't believe in the wall
separation
they'd rather get rid of the jettison
their Jefferson's metaphor in that
position the United States is a
Christian nation or at least a nation
that is built on Christian principles
and the founding father despite
historical evidence I would argue are no
different from the pilgrims they believe
in God they were motivated by Christian
principle they believed Christianized
political morality and our rent whispers
and writes that the law separation
between church and state is a metaphor
based on bad history metaphor which has
proved useless as a guide for judging
that should be frankly abandoned doesn't
wallace vs Jeffrey and like most
separatists he read quiz trying to
collapse american history in bryce trans
great and i wanted to quote from him
from a decision that school district of
benton 1963 his right he writes strange
way of writing history well the fact
that the founding fathers believed
devotedly that there was a god and the
rights of man who rooted in him is
clearly evidence in their writings from
the Mayflower Compact to the
Constitution itself and quote so as if
is collapsing many many years of
American history into one as if
Protestant thinking and alignment
thought were one of the same as if the
jealous God of the Old Testament was the
same thing as a creator of the
Declaration of Independence but remember
that the god of the director Clara
independence is not a jealous gun Walter
burns from the
book called making Patriots the creators
there is rights but that disappears he
doesn't condense it doesn't punish it's
not an old testament god it's the
sovereign people who have rights defend
their rights and and and make redefine
them quite kind of God well who knows
and who cares since in the republican
form of government can be without doctor
has Jefferson's venison tins is the
notes in Virginia which was translated
into fraction and widely read in France
as well observational so like MTV and
said the following quote it does me no
injury to say there are twenty gods of
no God neither picks my pocket no breaks
my leg and remember the Jeffersonian
spare time is elected president what is
it you are cuts and pastes takes the
gospel rewrite the Gospels in some
English will be become known as the
Jefferson Bible and it cuts out
everything that is there with miracles
with the resurrection and the end of the
Jefferson Bible is the following quote
and Joseph rolled a great stone to the
door to supporter and depart end of
Jackson's Bible which was published by
late in 1895 and republished by the
Congress in 1904 at that time the
Congress would give a free copy of
Jefferson's battle to every new elected
member of the Congress I'm afraid that's
not being done today
now in political science that the
example of the revival of this narrative
you find it a good example is in the
lead work of Professor Samuel Huntington
in a book called who are we she's read
about the American identity subtitle the
challenges to America's national
identity it's a book that came out 2004
and very much like when Prince
Huntington refuses to make a peer cut
distinction which in Puritan history and
period of founding fathers for him it's
it's in a weight's one of the same which
is a way of diminishing the importance
of the founding fathers and increasing
the importance of the Puritan of
experience in a good 2 billion fashion
and say this is why friends the
Huntington argues that what the American
creed is the unique creation of
descending Protestant culture or that
admits that the Creed has some element
of and enlightenment culture but
immediately added those ideas found
receptive ground in the angular
Protestant culture that had already
existed in America for over a century
and conclude the quote religion has been
it still is central perhaps this central
element
mervyn identity and that's why by the
way ha when he looks at spinnings the
immigration of the new migrant the new
Latinos for him their values do not sit
here he creamed off they cannot be
assimilated they are not compatible with
the American creed fact that has been
challenged by fukuyama wonderful armful
fujiyama brought about hunting is good
and forgiveness point where's the
Protestant today it's probably the
immigrant worker was much harder than
natives and that's where you find the
field trust the realty Protestant ethic
work ethic but also of adding
huntington's forgot how difficult how
was the integration of Irish Catholics
Italian Catholics in the United States
and that's why I'm a chapter on the
Bible wars and the point of the chapter
about awards and nineteenth centuries to
show them forgotten how violent have
instructed how vicious where the
conflict from Protestant leads and
Catholic Aneesa and migrants in the 19th
century and into quite a while for
for them to to be really similar and
thirdly revival new curate narrative of
course you find it in to this program's
initial Backman statement can Governor
Perry statement about the importance of
of Christianity it's not a new
phenomenon hoc committee when he was a
candidate in 2008 said in one of the
primaries that he wanted to christianize
the Constitution in rewriting the
preamble of the Constitution so and
there are things that are taking place
Bryson's Jeff Rossen recently showed in
a Bryson article that the influence of
Willard cleone scousers strange book the
five thousand leap 2820 great ideas that
changed the world that book was
published in nineteen eighty one and
that book is popularized by blending
from a circle University which you can
see moves for Friday Friday night
and is a key source of information for
seminars are being offered today in
Washington DC seminars are offered by
the National Center for Constitutional
studies which are tended by electric
member of the Congress and staff members
of the Congress and the point of the
seminars is to demonstrate a Christian
the nature of the American government
now for demonstration scouser uses a
argument which are called hair darien
referring to murder
romantic offer the journey he advocates
for instance a return to saxon liberties
he praises the superiority of
anglo-saxon thought and it's like
reading bankrupt again but a very
simplified simplistic bancroft written
again a kind of providential reading of
American history with an implicit
hierarchy or bracelet but living a
further I believe that the revival the
nail here at the narrative has a lot to
do with a southern strategy of the
Republican Party which rich really a
climax under the cottage Carter's
administration at a time when if you
look at this source the origin of the
moral majority which will help bring in
selection and you look at the key
organizer not so much full well but the
organizers rania the key struggle at the
time had a lot to do with a Christian
with a christian academy's now the
prison academies were private schools
that were developed in the south to
resist the desegregation that had been
inaugurated by legal decision but also
by the civil rights act and Carter had
made it clear that you would continue to
the christian academy's would not be
free of tax and it's at this point that
the sentimental is right which was not
politically organized became really
organized and became the Moral Majority
and so once eventually called for
concern evangelicals were given the
prominent place in the Republican Party
well it was clear that relief
values traditional family values would
become central to the platform of the
other grand old party transformation of
course with huge electoral consequences
and I would give a prominent place to
what I call the revival of the near
Puritan paradigm in in the party and in
the Tea Party movement today so let me
conclude now looking back to begin a
French perception of religion in America
and why they've changed over the year
and Marty I said very very nicely that
as kind of lack of curiosity about the
United States and currents more today
that mean the 18th century by the way
it's surprisingly there's less distance
between the continents and less and yet
we seem to not understand the United
States as well as we need to be its
incentive and I think part of the
problem is the inability of a Frenchman
understand evangelicalism as if the
first the Second Great Divide will have
never existed a part of the reason is
not that friends is not a secular
society but I think it has preserved the
restaurant Catholic culture in a secular
environment and this Catholic culture is
based on respect for order hi Rocky
discipline based on fear of operatively
expressed religious emotions fear also
tremendous competition fear of religious
entrepreneurship which makes it very
difficult for French commentators to
explain the rise of avenged little
failures slow to new phenomena
victorville Tocqueville who had a nice
abstract concept of the name had a real
problem dealing with avenge Alito
intended on number of Kent meetings in
the mid 19th century that's described
not in democracy in america with other
texts and we know that and when tokyo
describes and camp meeting he writes
that trouble and expresses real fear
about the future of American democracy
fear based on on a dual-threat fear of
skepticism on one hand that could lead
to socialism that's bad you know atheist
people but funerals are going to call it
stealing trends exactly an undisciplined
religion that could lead to Annika and
so he deploys that deplore a kind of
religiosity of sight of Allah reduced
men to the position approves and vote
insect in America and then it has a
solution
which is a kind of modernized Catholic
Church that could you the best church
for very high sense but the only French
thinker got a positive view of
evangelicalism is mahaska value a
student talk about facts a Samoan
economist and you came to America his
letters were published two years after
Tocqueville 1836 but it's not as well
known let's show at the end you know and
he was very much impressed by Kent
meetings on why because the important
place that was given to women because he
knows that after all women are not
political partisan they are not involved
daily politics they don't vote but they
are very much present and all the levels
could in the hierarchy of the
evangelical sex that he can observe and
he concludes that looking at their full
participants in Methodist and Baptist
revivals and he concludes that well
that's probably where real democracies
at work in religious minute now today
the very recent recent French
perceptions are following having have
afraid that when we do not understand
American politics we use the easy
stereotype easy reflection that are up
and they're all Puritans no wonder they
do this that and that stereotype so well
in time by 1925 person when start visits
the United States and similar move are
not together one after
other they come up with the same
reflection that indeed young Americans
are incredibly purity and they both even
claim that their peers and us in the set